as you know mr speaker i've taken the
obligation we have to the afghan
personnel who have supported us right
extremely seriously and despite this
disappointing event we should also pay
tribute to the armed forces for
operation pitting and that we managed to
evacuate 8
800 people and families eligible on the
arab scheme since april in addition to
the 1400 who'd already been reallocated
uh
relocated prior to that date however
worrying for me over the last few weeks
lapses from the highest standards and
management of these people remaining in
afghanistan have been brought to my
attention by both honourable members of
this house and indeed by others and it
is for that reason that ministers raised
concerns both last week and yesterday
and sought assurances these problems
would be rectified these assurances were
given however it was brought to my
attention at twenty hundred hours last
night there'd been a significant data
breach to say mr speaker i was angered
by this under was a understatement and i
immediately directed an investigation to
take place initial findings show that an
email was sent at 1744 hours as part of
the weekly contact we maintained with
arap currently remaining in afghanistan
and this was copied to all applicants
rather than blind copying them the email
was immediately recorded on
identification of the breach and then a
subsequent email was sent advising
people to delete the email and change
their addresses many of whom have done
so far one individual has been suspended
pending the outcome of the investigation
and processes for data handling and
correspondence processing have already
been changed i've directed extensive
steps are taken to quantify the
potential increased risk to individuals
in order to take further steps to
protect them the information
commissioner has been notified and we
will cooperate fully with any of their
own inquiries i apologize to those
afghans affected by this data breach and
with whom we are now working with them
to provide security advice
as i speak the ministry of the armed
forces is in the region speaking to
neighbouring countries to see what more
we can do with both third countries and
in-country applicants it is an
unacceptable level of service that has
let down the thousands of members of the
armed forces and veterans and on behalf
of the ministry of defense i apologize i
offer the reassurances that the scheme
will continue to operate and bring
people back to the united kingdom for
however many are eligible and however
long it takes